this
okay hi everyone welcome to another
design review language completeness and
consistency
looking at post version 13 world from
language
all right let's start off with with lock
returning dollar timed out
right so this is something that uh you
know there have been a couple of things
that's been discussed a couple of times
um
so we had a big survey of things that
return dollar timed out and basically
nothing was and we decided that failure
objects were better and
you know i i have here a couple of
examples so find equational proof
returns a failure with the literal tag
timed out url read doesn't
uh
use that exact tag in fact it's a little
weird that it both issues a message and
returns a failure but
you know i don't think that's bad i
don't think that's a bad policy thing
for to to it's your message but i do
think that it would be nice to
standardize the failure tags if we can
right
and so
the the failure tag um
zoo at this point
uh not in any sort of
comprehensive way no we haven't
what do you mean by failure tag do you
just mean a thing there this is like
connection failure yeah
okay because i mean i think there is a
mechanism for failure
maybe we should make this easier where
you can basically give it a message
a message name if you know what i mean
and and it will you know put it in the
tag and stuff like that i know some
functions like it's not it's not no no
it's not in the tag the way it works is
that the first argument is a tag second
argument is an association and the
message name is in the association so
the tag makes it very easy to pattern
matching and stuff like that
the message name not so much and it
at least when we first designed it for
interpreter it should not be much relied
on because some cases you might have the
same message name
uh or rather different message names for
the same kind of error just because we
wanted the failure to format differently
in a form
like okay so hold on so what you're
saying is that
wait a minute where's the tag
it's the it's the first argument
connection oh i see i see i see okay so
for example to keep an example if you uh
if you're doing a restricted of integer
and you restrict over even number or odd
numbers you get a different message name
just because we want the text to look
nice right so so message template would
you know can either be a string template
sort of thing or it can be a
you know like a message name that is and
its template is looking how does it know
is it a message name wrapper
uh is there a message name i think it's
just delayed or rule delayed i mean
no but
yes message right you know foo colon
colon bar right it has a full form of
message name symbol comma tag
no no uh
general colon colon whatever if you look
at its full form oh is message
yeah exactly
okay so what you're saying is if i say
general colon colon stop
yep and you look at its full form
yeah okay fine but so what what
christopher was saying was
that
in here it would be message template
colon greater than general stop or
whatever right and then then the message
parameters is what's fed into that
right
okay by the way i mean maybe one thing
that might be nice i mean if we think
that the paradigm of throwing a message
and then returning a failure is sort of
uh
should be promoted then yeah i mean it
might be nice to have a function that or
maybe even just um some usage of failure
that basically does that
i mean where it takes similar arguments
to message and maybe some others and
then it will print the message and turn
it into a failure object too
we want the message printed at the time
when the failure occurs internal to the
function whereas the failure
printing something failure will only be
disgorged at the end presumably maybe
that's not right well i mean it's just
like your message returns no but it
could return a failure object
christopher by the way there is a some
general utility function that does
exactly that it's a failure and prints a
message out of it
okay yeah i know there's functions that
like um take a call to message and then
turn it into a failure object or
something like that too so yeah i mean
it seems
it's or like take a failure object and
turn it into a message and yeah i mean
general utility there's a bunch of stuff
with this i think
okay you've raised the question should
message return a failure object as it's
about as its value well i was going to
argue that maybe there would be a usage
of failure well i don't know i feel i'm
not sure if you can really do that with
message because i'm sure stuff relies on
returning null
well okay so
i mean the whole message system
is pretty anti-diluvian
i mean for example is it still the case
that a message that the text of a
message has to be a pure string
yes
well it has to be a string but of course
that string might include
linear form constructs right well i mean
the template needs to be a string but of
course you can give any parameters you
want to that string
oh here but for example by the way a
problem with failure is that because
failure depending on how you put the
arguments into failure in some hair
splitting way it will um either use
string form like message does or it uses
what a string template which can't
insert arbitrary stuff in the same way
but that's a different issue
you mean in in the way that it inserts
things in message template
yeah so if you if you use if you set a
message template um and then you use the
um
uh
and then for the message parameters you
use an association instead of a list it
uses string template and string template
can't insert things in the same way that
message message uses string form to
insert things which lets you insert you
know summary boxes and whatever the heck
you want in a string
but
but
string template doesn't let you do that
it has to call to string on them which
you know yeah this sounds like a
potential lcc issue and it should be
investigated because that seems crazy
and i mean i've got a question the the
the um
uh wfr function when you use an obsolete
one and it gives you that message that
says press this button to get a new one
what is that how did that get
implemented
and is that it's still pretty ugly
do people know what i'm talking about
here
uh approximately it's not something i've
ever seen but i've heard you describe it
before
um but you know how we can generate one
uh
not off the top of my head um
i think we need bob s or somebody like
that
well i can just guess a function that
will have been updated i mean i think um
yeah or maybe you could just do the full
form of a resource function and then
edit the version number
i don't know if that would work but it
might work
um
i'm um right
assuming there's a literal button in the
message
then
um
you know that's presumably a button
that's written in linear syntax
um but of course i i don't think we want
you know
hey this is a trivial thing
can i just make a comment that the
function repository
should have something
that says in addition to recent
functions there should be a section here
for updated
just for what it's worth
if everybody could make it we got a note
of that pass it on
okay in any case sorry what were you
saying about um right
uh right so i'm saying that presumably
this button
if it's really part of a message and not
just something that it's cell printing
then it's presumably
using linear linear syntax or possibly
inserting the button as an argument into
the the message template
but of course i you know i don't think
we want
uh right i mean messages also need to
work in a standalone kernel so
you know having a string template that
you know will either convert things to
output form or standard form depending
on you know whether you're in a
standalone kernel or a notebook is a
pretty good thing if you start allowing
people to create you know row of grid of
you know why can't we run to that what
happens to that in standalone kernel
that works just fine well i guess row of
gray okay row of grid is fine but then
people start doing pain of panel of
whatever what do those do in a
standalone kernel uh they format as pain
open bracket blah blah blah
even an output form
yep
well that's the place where there's a
problem if we really care about those
things
uh well okay but let's come back to this
the original question here okay so
several different issues one is the
investigation of failure objects and
whether they are consistent in the way
that they're handling
uh different kinds of um
objects for message template and message
parameters that's one thing the second
what is counter
um
[Music]
that must be data that uh
that url read
stuck into the failure object
so you're allowed to add whatever
additional metadata you want into the
failure object into the association
yeah it's recording that there
right so maybe that's how many times
you've tried or
i i don't know i mean we should have
we're supposed to have somebody like
joel or fahim here who can answer these
questions i noticed uh both of those
people were here
okay
i do know
i don't know
why counter is there
okay
by the way this
reveals its bugginess because that
shouldn't say one seconds obviously but
but presumably this code should have
just had a quantity object fed in as a
parameter to the message here
why
why did it do that
because it was written by jonathan who's
not
you know super expert i guess
i mean we can fix that
that's just a junior era of junior
developer error that wasn't caught
but actually just just to
bring up the point again i mean i think
if you if if he did it where um where he
inserted the one seconds using an
association for the message parameters
which then makes it use uh string
template then it also might not have
formatted right using the quantity i'm
not sure
i get my formatting turned into
quantity of blah blah blah as opposed to
turning into so you're saying if i say
string template
of
you know hello
back tick back tick
and then i feed that
this as an argument
yeah i'm not totally sure what that will
do it probably depends on what the
default insertion function is
okay
that's pretty reasonable
yeah
but that's how it would have formatted
depending on how he put his message
parameters in as opposed to one second
okay let's return to the issue so first
point is we believe that message
continuing to return null as print does
there's no choice about that
point one point two i mean wouldn't it
be nice if there was something more like
echo that was a message-y type thing or
does that not make any sense no it
doesn't make any sense never mind that i
mean
you could imagine something
that is for example for confirm you can
imagine something that you rap
somehow okay if a confirm is going to
fail
is there an easy way to make a message
from that
what do you mean by that i mean
confirmed generates a failure object
when it
fails if you know what i mean no i
understand that but i'm asking the
question if you wanted to print
something and you know in real time
when a confirmed triggers you know when
a confirm
doesn't dis does not confirm
that's very easy you just put it in the
input the second argument the second
army argument only gets evaluated when
the confirmed triggers
i see so you would just say so it's not
a wrapper but you would put what would
you put there
you just say
is it a function
what is it no it's just a it's a it's a
just an expression because that's the
information field that'll get given to
the failure object that eventually gets
propagated up to the enclosed but it
also only gets evaluated you know it's
like the second argument first right
where it's just an expression that only
gets evaluated if it's needed okay but
the fact is you are generating a failure
object and there could be some way of
just saying
message something about the failure
object given that you know what the
failure object is
what exactly do you mean message
something about the failure well i mean
i mean print just like here we're
printing a message
that is connected to the failure object
oh i see and the code is separate here
between in other words there could be
some some mechanism to just say
whatever whenever a failure object is
generated print something associated
with the generation of that failure
object
so in other words we could even have
a thing well i think that that should be
dealt with so that should be handled at
the enclosed level though right the
confirm should fail because basically
the argument structure of confirm makes
it very hard for it to take things like
options so i think what should happen is
that confirm should do its thing and
return up to the enclosed and then the
enclosed should you know handle whether
it wants to throw it back out as a
message
and if there was a function for example
like there is in general utilities i
think that just takes a failure object
and basically converts it to a message
um
then you would just put that in the
second argument and close and it would
it would do it okay so maybe we need
that function but but it's not quite
echo failure
it is something that says you know
message well message failure sounds
wrong
um but what it is it's just taking
the failure object and
yeah maybe message could take a failure
oh yeah i mean it can't return one but
it could just take a picture yeah it
could take a failure object why not
although i'm not sure what structure it
needs to have in the failure object in
order to actually throw it as a
well-formed message well i mean the
failure object already contains the
message template and arguments so
there's no well it can be a string so
it might not be a message it might not
have a message name is the point
well then it has to give a generic one
then we could do that's a good idea
message could just eat a failure object
well but by the way what one other point
maybe is that any any time you know
there's a strong urge i think among
developers to be like oh we should have
uh you know you want to be able to write
your message you know the body of the
message inside of the code where the
error is generated but then every time
this is brought up someone mentions that
for localization the messages can't you
know can't be just strewn about in the
middle of the code
and so if we have something where you
can throw arbitrary failure objects uh
you know without providing a message
name without doing that then that could
be an issue
you mean a developer control issue so to
speak i mean oh no it's a user issue
right so we have right we have japanese
messages and we have chinese messages
and the way this works is we have the
message tag
and then
you know all messages are supposed to of
course they're not but they're supposed
to be
put in the central messages
repo and then the localization team
knows they need to translate these
messages into
you know may i suggest a procedural
change here you know why don't we just
admit it's english first the english
version is in the code the thing is
harvested we harvest plenty of things
for documentation and so on just harvest
the stuff from the code and then the uh
you know the the message colon colon
name colon colon language stuff which is
the you know the localized version is
then
you know inserted based on that
harvesting is it not inserted in the
code but it's inserted in a central
location
as a secondary
uh you know as a secondary
representation of the message
yeah but then you're you're scanning the
entire code base all the time for that
and
you're complicating the process for dqa
well
that and also which strings right now
now
right because there are cases which are
not great cases
where the message is literally backtick
one and then the actual message text is
in the second argument of message
so and now and and then you can go
further and imagine that actually that's
a variable that's constructed through
string concatenation or something
well how does that work right now in the
in the um centralized message
it doesn't it's just broken right i mean
that's not localizable to start with so
that it's not
i mean people already you know there's
like i know several like i think in the
compiler and other projects like that
you know they just do this and basically
the messages aren't localized but i mean
there's a strong urge that people you
know developers want to write the
messages
having messages in the code is useful i
think it's it's helpful in having the
code be correct it's easier to maintain
it is something we do in the
documentation all the time is scan the
whole documentation base which is pretty
big at this point for things that
require consistency changes
i i don't see the problem of doing that
even i i think there's another issue
here which is like this thing where the
message is basically
backtick one backtick and then it's
filled in
v via code it's it's literally like you
you have some logic for plurals and
whatnot
that actually performs some computation
to produce the correct message
that stuff requires an entire framework
for localization like we would need to
standardize that i think yes
which we've done somewhat for wolf and
alpha but we haven't done in other
places
okay look the fact that we can't
right i mean we we're we're not going to
solve that today so
let's let's zoom out to what we actually
are solving we want message to take the
failure object as an argument that's a
good idea
i think and we probably need some
examples and then close of how to use
that
i think that's one one takeaway another
takeaway is i personally support the
idea of just you know doing what people
have been doing anyway and saying you
put messages in the english messages in
the main code and we have a harvesting
process i think i mean we don't have the
right people in this meeting to discuss
that idea but i think that's a good idea
and the third thing the actual question
that was asked here about with lock
returning dollar timed out um
the argument here is that
it should in fact return failure object
not dollar time doubt is that correct
and is anybody supporting the idea that
it should return dollar time doubt
well
the
fact that the times out isn't really an
error
but uh
i mean it means
when you when you use with lock you you
are prepared for there'll be several
processes to fight for for a resource
and so the question is if you're not
this not willing to wait forever then
you may decide i wait for two seconds
and if i don't get a locket with
something else and i return or i i give
up
so
i don't really care what what it returns
as long as it's something that is
extremely easy to test for and if it's
some failure object with a hundred of
different cases then
i mean failure objects are nice but they
are so general that for one we should
really have some internal guidelines for
how we create our own failure objects
and if it has a unique tag like
timed out then failure of timed out is
just as good as the
dollar time okay but let me argue why
failure is a better option so to speak
as opposed to the usual failure is not
an option but
why failure is a better option is that
things like confirm
immediately know how to deal with
failure
whereas i doubt the confirm knows you
know in other words if it's dollar times
point at the bottom of this section is
that concern probably should support
dollar time doubt which is well
it's a question i guess i i left off the
question mark but it was
uh should conf should i mean this was a
question that was raised in the last
conversation and we didn't have
christopher so
should right i mean the the right the
the direction we were heading in was
that dollar time doubt would be sort of
a symbol for users to use and you know
system symbols should use
failure objects now
should confirm also do something with
dollar times out
i guess i don't have a strong opinion
what else does confirm what other
special cases does confirm deal with it
probably deals with aborted yeah aborted
maybe cancelled uh cancelled yes
um you'll have to look at the rough page
i can't i can't sorry
dollar failed surely right yes yeah
dollar failed anything that's failure
queue uh dollar cancelled i think also
missing
um probably dollar cancelled works would
confirm but it's not failure queue
i think it is not i think it's not
failure queue i'm not sure they're
definitely i know it's not failure
well clearly this list it will be
consistent ad dollar timed out to this
list but what is dollar time doubt does
dollar timed out have a have a life or
is it wasn't introduced for this one
function
it was something that was introduced
many years ago but then never actually
really used by anything
um
and and so you wanted uh you right the
reason this all started is you wanted to
a survey of dollar time doubt versus
time constraint
and we
uh you know surveyed what user nothing i
don't think that i think there might be
a string argument time out in some
things but there's not a
symbol timeout and dollar time doubt
isn't actually
right that generates an actual abort
right so right so
time constraint here act literally
aborted
the computation and that that the board
bubbled up and can you know you can
handle it however you want to
handle aborts which if you
well not only that but right i mean
that right this is no different than you
typing pause of 10 and then after one
second deciding to hit control c and you
get dollar aborted
right i mean
a literal abort was generated
yeah i mean i think this is a
you know there was no failure everything
operated is intended right unless you
consider it unless you you think of time
constrained as a thing that's to protect
against stuff that's not running too
that argument is similar to with lock
with lock has the same issues there
isn't really a failure it's just timed
out based on the lock
so maybe this is a bit of a crazy
i'm not sure if this makes sense but
maybe we could even do something where
the tags in the failure objects are
symbols it's like the tag instead of it
being quotes timed out or something it
would be dollar time doubt which would
have the advantage that one you can
document dollar timed out and two you
know that everything that times out is
going to use the same tag which makes it
easier to test for
i'm not sure why why it's an advantage
to have it be a symbol other than it
kind of raises the stakes for it
i mean yeah it's just that you know that
all the dollar time doubts are going to
be the same as opposed to being quotes
timed out or time out or you know
evaluation timed out or whatever well
but i mean we can also standardize the
strings
okay the next question is if we look
right now an inventory at failure
strings failure tags what do we see
there's no easy programmatic way to get
all of those is there
no it requires scanning the code
so we have uh right i mean i think you
know there are sort of consistent
families within
areas of implementation right so
interpreter has it which was the
original user of failure you know has
its set uh the i think the url foo
family of functions has
a relatively consistent set image
processing maybe carlo or shady can
speak about that but i you know i think
dave
we don't have term failures though you
don't return failures yet okay so what
do you sometimes failures internally uh
we still have the unevaluated term to be
it has issues that maybe should be
discussed at another point
okay
okay so what what further things are to
discuss here the question is should with
lock return
dollar timed out
which honestly is beginning to seem more
consistent if if
if confirmed supports dollar time doubt
if time constraints
returns dollar aborted and so on
okay
right but then what's the rule that
distinguishes between the things that
return failure objects and things that
return
dollar time doubt i mean i can tell you
why time constraint behaves differently
right it's because a literal abort was
generated right yeah i know in in in
with lock there's no abort right it's
doing some stuff and then it decides
okay i'm done
yes well url read also look in a sense
with lock and time constrained are front
and center
time constraining type functions
whereas url read is mostly i just want
to read a url
and if i return something other than
that something went wrong
as opposed i mean i could make an
argument that these functions with lock
and time constrained are
you know they're intentionally
time constraining functions well they're
not really time constraining with lock
is not a constraining function right
it's uh
ensuring
right it's uh
okay fair enough it's a negotiation
function
right with lock is another example where
like url read you know the time time
doubt is sort of a failure i suppose or
maybe you can
right it didn't execute expert because
it wasn't able to
get the lock within
the
you know time
you know
time limit that was specified
all right you're making a reasonable
argument that that should return a
failure object which is i think the
original discussion here yep
and and that
the secondary issue is the
standardization of tags within failure
objects which requires an inventory of
what the tags actually are right now yep
yeah if you want me to change with lock
to return affiliate object it has to be
standardized documented and
extremely easy to to handle right well
yeah i mean well there
well i guess one question is right um
well i guess why the why do you need
something
special and in particular how would you
have this thing you know why is dollar
time right why is the fact that it
returned dollar time that special i mean
what if the user wrote some function
that returned
dollar time doubt
so would it be better for this to be
like a width lock timeout or something
uh the tag
i mean you can certainly do
well you're arguing look there's two
different directions here which probably
suggests segmenting the tags
one is christopher's claim it'll be nice
to know generically that something timed
out and therefore have a timed out tag
and your point there are different
shades of timing out i'd like to know
which one of these it was
okay so how do we deal with that
i mean unfortunately and this relates to
a thing we've discussed several times
recently
you know
the the underground tunnels of failure
are less well programmed than the above
ground what the program was supposed to
do
and that's always going to be a feature
you know there are very few people who
are going to write as carefully all the
failure paths as they write the success
paths
and therefore
you know the best we can do is to
provide sort of heuristic
i i don't know i mean in other words the
people who are going to care about those
shades the question is what will be a
case where one would care was this a
timeout i i think that's probably more
important
than the shading of this was a with lock
timeout as opposed to something else
in other words
yeah go ahead yeah i don't necessarily
disagree with that but you didn't give
roman a chance to actually answer my
question which is right he's he he's
insisting it's super important that he
be able to easily identify this dollar
timed out
so
what why does he need to do that and
does it matter if it's a timed out from
with lock or a dollar timed out from
you know the user function which
happened to return dollar time doubt now
if i decide to use the time constraint
option then
it is because
i i think that the the
the lock i'm willing to handle that the
lock not being available within some
time and then
i need to catch that and do it and do
something about it i might just return
an error to the calling code or i might
do something else or have a loop try
again
so i would expect any code that uses
with lock and the time constraint option
to
test for that time constraint your point
is your point is this a failure might be
generated the actual return value of
expert might be a failure object and you
would be deeply confused if you had
given a time constraint you got a
failure object it's like where did this
failure object come from did it come
from my time constraint or did it come
from just the natural evaluation of
experts yes but i mean that's dope for
probably 90 percent of our code i mean
any code that returns dollar failed will
will mess up the failure handling of the
enclosing code well it said no i don't
think that's the right way to do it
anyway because um you know
with lock of with lock could end up you
know having the inner width lock
generate a dollar timed out but yeah but
then you test choice before you return
the outer one
um
exactly right you've got you've got
internal state to the with lock
implementation that tells you that it
was with lock that's timed out and not
that expert returned dollar timed out
and therefore it timed out
yeah i mean if if you really want wanted
to insist on on the on on that then
probably the best
way in terms of programming would be to
generate an exception and not return
something when the timeout appears then
you can you can handle the exception
but that has some issues if that happens
uh
if somebody types this on top level then
there's no no handle right yes i yes and
yes i mean i i understand that i'm in
the minority but i i have
deep objections to that just because of
the number of java programs i've written
where somebody didn't bother to put in
the exception handling sorry i've used
where somebody didn't bother and all of
a sudden i'm seeing this random stack
trace and it just aborts even if the
stack race happens to have
how do we even generate an exception
what would we mean by generate an
exception
well that that would be like a throw or
of some kind or or something or maybe
right you know
yeah throw confirmation anything off
that
what is that christopher did we ever put
in
a
a guaranteed failure confirm
you mean like confirm never no we didn't
but i think it might be worth doing
i know this has been requested a few
times and we sort of said we sort of
like there was one at one point i think
it was called confirmed never and then
we kind of took it out because it was
like oh we can just run confirm
assertive false or confirm if dollar
failed
but i've heard enough people say they
want it that it might be worth adding in
again
confirm leather just seems like a such a
bizarre
construct
okay
so
i'm not quite understanding what to do
here the argument for with dollar time
doubt
is that it is a little bit
i think it's a bit dangerous that the
innards of a with lock could return a
failure but not be because of timing out
i mean they could return timed out as
well like a nested wood lock or
something like this
comments what do people think we should
do so we've got these two choices either
it's a failure object
where you expect
i mean the only way that you know that
with lock failed
is by looking at its return value
and therefore that would require people
who look at the return value to go look
at that failure object and check that it
matches the pattern which is kind of
ugly
although although we could just you know
right i mean if if with lock
right if with lock returns
you know
connection fail well i mean first of all
people do that all the time right
because they want to know
what you know how it failed or why it
failed um but also you know with lock if
it always returned failure of
quote time out or even failure of with
lock timeout if we really want to
particularize it although i don't based
on the conversation i don't think we
need to do that then all you need to do
it's a failure and you know i believe
you can get a i mean you can do first on
it but i think there's also uh
a sub value to just ask for the tag
um if there isn't i think there should
be
right because you can do failure of
properties to extract you get
extractable properties
um
yeah i mean actually if there was a
unique failure that would identify that
failure with lock timeout or failure of
timeout
and there was an easy way to test it i
mean that was the second
second of my requirements and at the
moment it doesn't seem to be that easy
to say is this a failure with a
particular attack
it's first
well at the first you have to test
whether it is a failure and then you
have to look at it and that is kind of
clumsy should failure queue missing
queue have some tag parameters to check
for what kind of missing what kind of
failure that's a good idea yeah i mean
so so failure queue right we we i don't
know that christopher did any work on
this but at
you know at the previous meeting about
the general issue of confirm and friends
we decided that
um
you know we need sort of a second
argument to
uh for failure queue and missing queue
to you know what we want to consider
and that certainly could include being a
specific tag but also sort of classes of
like maybe only
dollar failed and dollar aborted or and
you know missings are fine in in
i think it's a good idea i think that
will be a solution here so that the
rather
sorry go ahead
well i'm just saying the wrapper around
a width lock will be a failure cue the
test with failure q blob comma
time timeout
time quotes time out
testing for that tag in the failure
object yeah that that seems like an
elegant solution
but now okay i guess the the maybe one
question is this thing we talked about a
while ago
um
probably about a year ago actually um
about um having sort of
certain arguments like you know abort
quote aborts or something like that in
the second argument of failure queue
that might conflict if we also have a
you know if you can also put a a a
particular tag if you get what i mean
like is the second argument you give it
sort of a class of of types of failures
or is the second argument a specific tag
because i know right that really is a
name oh well i mean you could have both
if one of them was a symbol if dollar
failed if failure q of x become a dollar
failed
it's kind of crazy because you could
just say expert equals equals equals
dollar failed
well i suppose we could allow
uh
you know sort of uh
simple patterns right so uh right if you
if you
blank failure
and
or blank missing if you you know if you
want to be sort of more specific
uh i'm trying to find
yeah
since this was close to a year ago i'm
trying to look up the ticket right now
just so i can refresh my memory on
exactly
uh what was we decided
uh they also i mean we could have
something where it's just um
we could also have something where if it
doesn't know if it hasn't heard of quote
aborts or hasn't heard of time out then
it will assume that you're just talking
about a tag and otherwise it will you
know if it does know but a general class
of errors it'll test for that which
might be useful also because then you
could have it's that failure queue of
blah blah comma quotes you know timeout
or time timeouts or something like that
it could match both a failure object
with timeout and it could also mask
dollar time out
right yes
but my question would be
one of the issues is
if there is a class name
you're saying people who write failure
objects should avoid the class name
but unfortunately that's a slippery
slope because one can imagine adding a
useful class name at some point in the
future
after people have written a bunch of
failure objects that happen to use the
name that corresponds to the class name
well maybe every time maybe if there is
a class name right like if i've defined
timeout as a timed out as a class name
maybe failure queue comma quotes timeout
matches both failures that have that tag
and anything in the card
that's probably reasonable
that would be a reasonable way to do it
fine because i can't imagine a time you
have quotes time out and you don't want
it to match a failure with that tag
so i agree
all right that seems reasonable it's a
little bit heuristic but the fact is
again my claim is as you as soon as you
go subterranean dealing with the error
cases it's going to be heuristic
if you expect it not to be heuristic
people are going to wind up they're just
not going to write that code they're not
going to do that as carefully
as they do the main above ground stuff
um and they're just going to be happy
that we caught something that they
thought we might not even catch
all right
okay let us move on
all right next i did want to say on the
subject of
going through the code for all the
messages for localization yes um if the
plan is to include arguments to message
not just the message name
then i would talk to the wolfram alpha
localization team for their experience
with doing that kind of thing
sounds reasonable to me what is your
summary can you summarize it's been good
bad and different
horrifying
it's what i mentioned before where
there's you know it works but there's
the risk of i'd of
not properly identifying whether a
string is intended for code or whether a
string is intended for um i understand
i'm i'm telling you this is going into
the sub basements yep
this you know and let's get the main
cases because
you know yeah
they
um and also paclets do support separate
message
assets and so there's really no excuse
for putting the messages right inside
the code anymore
well maybe we should provide utility
that can extract things for paclets to
make it easier for people because i
think there is an argument for putting
the messages inside the code because
when you're reading the code for example
the messages give you some clue about
what's going on in the code and if you
have to go indirect and find it in some
other file you might not do it you might
well but you you should at least use
message tags and so you already have
that's true i mean and the message tag
whether it's at the top of the file or
in a separate messages or them file
i mean it will usually start out at the
top of the source run before the initial
release then you should really clean up
the mess and then put it into a messages
of them file i don't know about that i'm
not convinced i think we should leave
them in the code and have it be
harvested
you know perhaps it has some special
comments or some special tagging
well
i mean
i mean there's those logistical issues
are also some implementation issues with
how messages are looked up it's i mean
all i'm saying is let's not have this
discussion now right okay let's move on
json and data set
right
so we have two formats right we have i
mean we have have more but they're more
specialized right we have the the
original json implementation and then we
have the newer json implementation
written by
dorian um
and please don't skip ahead because
there's a point here okay
right so they both in most cases and
that's sort of a key point that i will
get to later
import the same data um
and sort of if you take the raw json
result and just wrap it in data set you
get this nicely formatted data set
if you take sort of the default json
importer you get this very ugly and slow
to format thingamajig which
i know maybe is a bug in data set
because right they're basically the same
shape only one is association and
a bunch of nested associations and the
other is a bunch of nested lists of
rules so i'm not sure why
right and so the complaint is oh it's
hard to
import json
nicely and easily because you either
need to know to use raw json and then
wrap it in data set or
do fancy you know map association
everywhere
um
so so that's the background so what do
we so here
so let's go now that we're all
understanding what the starting point is
just so i understand that the complaints
are
the word raw is unfortunate and people
would prefer raw jason to be the default
for jason is that one of the claims some
of some people would like that yes
okay and the second complaint is that
lists of rules and the reason we had
lists of rules for the json return maybe
association didn't exist at the time but
even if they did not it did not okay but
but maybe
uh but the other also
the repeat exactly that that is the
other issue that's what's what we're
getting to
okay all right
right so
so question number one do we want to
change the default association of json
import so there's obviously a large
backward compatibility issue
and
not all json issue files can be
represented because of the repeating
keys and so this is a question for
dorian what does happen in raw json does
it can it catch this or does it just
drop the duplicates or what happened
to be honest i don't remember but i
think i'm constructing the association
so
whatever
yes probably so
i remembered
at some point i think i think it does i
think you're right you just construct
the association and then the association
zaps the earlier versions of the keys
now i i think you might want to have an
option or they might want to be yet
another json format which has something
which changes the keys to have a dash 2
or something
if they are repeated
or maybe it just has a it just merges
them like it just gives a list for every
key
so it has a merging function or leaves
it leaves it the same as the
again
lots of the other sort of outside json
importer exporters have the same problem
nobody handles it exactly the same but
you document which way you handle it um
yeah but that's not good enough i mean
people might actually want i think the
merging function i mean we have the
capability of doing a merge
that technically changes the structure
of the data
and
i think that's all fine as long as it's
clear what options are do what
right fine i prefer having separate
elements or options that you can choose
to get a list of rules or an association
you should be able to get both
that's the reason well why not
well i mean you could maybe also just
there could be a don't we already have
an option called merging function or
something like that somewhere i mean
maybe that could just default to last
which is i think what association does
but if you set it to identity or
whatever you want then you'll you'll get
probably need to well
it shouldn't do any merging but if you
opted and used some you know merging
option then that would be fine
right but i'm just saying by not doing
any merging that's equivalent to merging
functionary last i mean that's how
merging function works i think in other
functions
that's how merge works oh well well
that's how
there's some function i think that yeah
i know the there is it's like an
association
or something like that has
sorry
the persistence symbol i think as a
merged function
option
or local symbol
oh yes local symbol uh it's not
persistent
do have a merging function so if you
look up a value and you find values at
different scopes then the question is
how do you construct a return value so
by default it uses the most local one
and you but you might also want to use
just a list of a flattened list of all
of them and things like that
so that's really that's different from
association merging i guess yes
okay never mind then i mean i thought
there was some i thought we may have
already had some options that does
association version i thought like for
there might be a system option
oh god
exactly everything's gonna blow up if we
if we touch that exactly okay so hold on
i mean by the way if there isn't i mean
that's something that we should have i
mean there are several association
functions that need that anyway like
association like one of the usages of
association map and stuff like that
where where you can get things where you
have key collisions and right now it
just takes the last one but often you
don't want that why can't we use merging
function why can't we start introducing
merging function for that purpose
seems like it does the same thing
well it sounds like well i don't think
we can use it literally in association
just because no
but in things that eat associations i
think that make or return associations
or produce or generate associations
exactly
seems sensible to me i mean i i don't
see why we can't use this exact function
merging function it seems like it has
exactly the right behavior
in the way it was used in persistent
symbol we just want to expand on that
okay so
question here
um
uh all right so
what sean is suggesting which i agree
with is different elements that give
either an association i mean we could
just give a data set directly back
what would happen
yeah i see so that the issue is when
people just say import comma.json or
they don't give a
an element at all they just import a
file that's a json file the complaint is
that what comes back is not as beautiful
as it could be
right
that is annoying i agree that is
annoying
i think there is also some value in the
way it currently works in that it's kind
of lossless
yeah exactly the things we're talking
about are either structure changing or
straight up lossy so
well fair enough but that that might
suggest then that it's simply an element
to json rather than this raw json idea
that the things we want like an
association of data set whatever become
you know we say import blah blah dot
json comma data set
right although if it's going to be
structurally different i i think i think
then we do want to merge the formats and
of course we there's no cost to
continuing to support raw json as a
synonym for json but
right i think we we would want names for
you know import as the current json
import as the current raw json import as
a data set
um
yes okay fine so those become elements
of the json case
right
and with raw json just a convenience
thing
a top-level convenience thing
exactly
that's fine
so i i have a question why does data set
not support a good visualization with
list of rules what is this
that is one of the questions i raise in
possible resolutions
maybe jose can
say something about that he's probably
our biggest expert
has never done it there is
i think
i think
lists of rules
are not the same thing as associations
and data set has always been been based
on associations and lists being
the main right in particular in
particular the extractors for lists of
rules are not the same as the extractors
although lookup works on a list of rules
yep i mean many right keys does values
does many many of the association
functions will treat
yeah i suppose i don't know if it's
defined uh what what they do if uh
you have duplicate keys uh like if you
do
that part for example
so well yes with party they're right
there they're
really quite different
right my question is if the data set
element is going to support those 250
keys
is it going to behave more like the
listed
association
which is why i think if it was an option
the option for control for associations
and data sets
whether or not you delete them we could
use something like delete duplicates
which already exists in csv
in my opinion it's very easy to go from
the list of rules to the association
if that's needed so it shouldn't be
there so that's what they said
i'm sorry you say it should not be the
responsibility of data set exactly
because you just wrap association around
it and it makes it an association
but then the question is that's a
duplicate killing operation
that is correct
rapid association that's correct
but i think what's happening
what
i mean if if you wrap a list of rules
with association you know what's going
to happen so you have control over it so
you have the decision
right but but yeah but it's not but if
what you have is already a nested list
of rules making the replacement is not
super easy
right
exactly right uh i in fact would replace
repeated work in this case who knows
that's not how not how you want it to no
yeah i'd use this
yeah yeah that's pretty ugly you you end
up with your sort of custom matching
rules
okay
listen listen
if the main thing is
we're going to get nested rules from
json import clearly what should happen
is there should be a data set
element
for json import
there should be a merging function or
delete duplicates option that will
control this issue about what to do with
the duplicates
i mean i think another thing people
might want is generative messages there
are duplicates
that make sense i mean
you know
delete get rid of the duplicates but
generate a message to tell you there was
a duplicate because it might actually be
just a bug
right so i think sean needs to come up
with a list of potential element names
which are
and or options
that control essentially getting
the thing we call json
into these various forms that include
data sets
okay and we potentially downgrade the
value of raw json and upgrade the value
of json comma data set basically
does that make sense it seems sensible
to me
okay
all right
then i think that's that's what we
should do
okay but we're keeping the current
default element because we're
i don't think we can change that and i
and i think the lossless round trip is a
good argument for it and i think it's
fine
okay and i mean by the way
what we could do and this is a user
assistance thing when you type in
you know here's a possibility there's no
reason why import if it sees you type a
dot json file couldn't bring up
something that is essentially a
suggestion about import elements
see what i'm saying
right
john do we have an infrastructure for
that
i mean i think we have something oh
uh but uh what sorry what what kind of
suggestion would it be right well i
would imagine i don't exactly know i
mean it would be probably something i
haven't thought about it but it will be
something where you're basically making
a suggestion about what the
potential
next argument would be
right well i think i mean
and would you do this before somebody
writes a comma i mean if somebody writes
a comma i think we can
i mean well i was thinking it'd be nice
to give some indication before you do
the comma like there's a file now well
okay you can't just look at the
extension because import uses file
format which has all kinds of other
heuristics and stuff you can't always
just look at that much no i understand
if there is an extension if there is an
explicit extension
then you have a fighting chance of of
suggesting the right things
you do but i
you wouldn't want to give a suggestion
for a format that it's not actually
going to import that so if you type
after this comma and then list
and give a format then you can give good
suggestions
no but that's then you've lost the game
no no look not really that's how you
specify elements
i'm well aware i'm well aware right but
i'm saying the point that i'm making is
we are trying to message to users the
fact that oh you know they say they just
say import of the file and they don't
know to use elements and then they say
oh it's a really ugly import what am i
going to do i'm lost right so if they
type json making the suggestion that
they could type
as the actual thing to import you know
json comma dataset or something i
haven't thought this through this is a
user assistant thing it's just a
suggestion for how to
educate users on what the possible
elements are so they're not go ahead i i
agree that that's useful i think it
might be useful in more scenarios than
just import
and
i i think i i understand what sean says
about uh format guessing if you want to
suggest elements based on just the
extension i think it has to be very
clear assuming json format
you know comma something that makes
sense so indicate that it might be it it
isn't i mean you can do that by having
the thing it's suggesting be json comma
data set
and if you know it isn't in fact a json
file you know that that would be the
wrong thing so i don't know that i'm not
solving this um you know user assistance
problem right here
um
okay can we move on quickly we just have
a
you know
yeah
yep so this one um i think
it's i i don't think this is
as big an issue as i thought at first
but i i and i think this is partly a
communication problem but
and that now the people are using a lot
of the same words but not perhaps
necessarily using them the same way
um
right so we have these things that are
sort of like controls like molecule draw
that you know pops up a little interface
that you can use to create molecules
um
but
it's not written in a way where you can
um
what the heck i thought i was getting
some kind of ringy thing
that's very unaromatic
okay
i don't understand this
okay uh well
jason can speak up i i will not uh
yeah criticize nor defend uh the
implementation of molecule draw because
i have not it's been a long time since i
looked at it and it was very early on
when i okay
i don't understand what it's doing here
i don't understand why this ring thing
isn't
why i don't get a ring now i do get a
ring okay
that's a bug
i pr i clicked on ring i didn't get a
ring
well
which is to say you click on it and then
you click where you want to place it
well no no i think what happened is he
just clicked on the sort of drop down
generator and that didn't change the
tool it
yes that's right exactly
okay tell us a drop down that's just ux
bug
should get fixed okay so what's your
point so your point is this has a return
here
right so i guess this is all right so i
guess this is sort of right it's
blocking the kernel and then it returns
this thing and it's not very nice
to integrate into forms or manipulate
um
and
i guess there's this other thing that
exists in the cloud but i i'm not
familiar with it with geo position
figure
yeah there's uh this thing that people
in wp have been developing for getting a
nice little map
on on in a form
and the problem is that it's it's kind
of difficult to uh
to integrate if there is no equivalent
thing in the desktop so i don't have a
symbol
to to use when i do the form
specification even if it's automatic
it should have something like input
field or slider yes well you could
certainly make it a string for the time
being but i agree that it needs that
and it's not i mean it's not terribly
difficult to do something that almost
kind of works on the desktop that does
it's basically a locator pane of with
geographics
with dynamic geographics
but i mean
zooming in and out doesn't work but it's
almost there and i think i mean at some
point we had this kind of summits about
you know current value and remote value
and what different controllers for
sensors and stuff would look like and
then
and then we kind of lost that
very nice and consistent thing we were
doing and random groups started
implementing things with slightly
incompatible interfaces so i think it is
a consistency issue what were we calling
sorry the the thing oh my gosh what was
it called that the thing you just
mentioned the thing that had remote
value or or client
client value that was the idea so client
value had this possibility where okay
you are um
taking a picture for example there are
multiple things you could do you could
take a whole movie and um you know start
the movie take it finish it send it in
you could capture the current picture
you could
go
you could have something where it's it's
some where you press take a picture and
then you submit it you have something
where it's continuously ingesting the
picture and sending it to the functions
and so on
and so we had a taxonomy of those
different i think there were four or
five different cases yes i think we're
using a magnetometer as the standard
example where you either want the
current magnetic field you want to wave
the thing around and record a time
series of magnetic fields or you might
want to take a reading and then
subsequently feed in the magnetic field
yeah but it's it's not just uh sensors
like for example there's no reason why
wouldn't have some kind of molecule
picker that binds to a dynamic and then
can be used to manipulate or in a form
yes i understand yeah
we could generalize this client value
thing to saying do you do the picking
offline
and then you say submit it now
or is it more like a dynamic
where it is where the picking
is being dynamically fed into the
function continuously is that a fair
characterization yeah that's the
continuous action option for input field
for example right so so right so i mean
we sort of have those things here right
so like
image capture brings up this interface
and you can
as opposed to current image which just
takes the picture
right so current image just takes the
picture and returns it dynamic of
current image you know is continuously
taking a picture and and drawing it in
in the dynamic output
um and then image capture on some level
it's nice right it prints out this
little interface that you can click on
to take a picture but then you can't
you can't programmatically do anything
with that picture you've taken because
it's basically copied to the clipboard
so you can or maybe you can save it in a
file and but and paste it but you can't
sort of programmatically use that
um
what did we think about for client value
we had a mechanism for using that
yes i think we had a discussion in
possibly relevant things yeah
okay
which is i think we're going to run
pretty old it's 2015 on on twiki
oh for goodness sake
well i think i've got these files
because i've got um
uh i mean at some point we renamed it
client value i think i've got a whole
folder of stuff about client value
um
yeah here we go
there we go lots of stuff
what's the dates on these
oh 2015.
once from 2017.
recorded values
packet capture go
oh
what's that yeah
the curl of these cases when it binds to
a dynamic and i think it's nice because
it's the one that i can use in forms and
that luke can use in
manipulate
so right this is a more complicated
discussion
somebody's got to go through these files
um avery could pick them up and send
them out to people
the ones from that directory
perhaps it's time you know it sounds
like it's time to finally get client
value
under control and implement it
um
because i'm not sure that
the client values the right name for
something which is i'm not sure there's
a point on a map
i'm not sure it is either i mean
in fact i'm not sure client value is the
the right name for anything unless
you're evaluating you know how much
money you eat a company is giving us
right
right i i just don't know how to parse
that i didn't even think of that okay
but but yeah like remote value i can
understand though let me explain why it
was qualified value okay okay it's
called that because well imagine that
there were things that were locally
being computed on a phone on a browser
that was the
client device
was doing a computation i see
that was that's the idea now
what you're generalizing as long as it's
not running an x if it's running access
the server device exactly
i was just thinking that john
can we call it
yeah right there um
uh
let's tell you some interesting history
about back some person who wrote it but
anyway that's a different story
um
the uh
anyway
um
right so you had this client device and
that's why you were calling it client
value that's correct but but but
generalizing it to these controls like
molecule drawing geopicker or whatever
geolocation picker geoposition picker
seems completely sensible and it's the
wrong name for that
um and and in fact the very fact that we
haven't implemented it for seven years
does suggest that its importance on
client devices like phones is not as
great as i mean i well
there was a point in time when um
i think we deliberately down prioritize
this as
uh
you know
things on on the phones in in terms of
you know the the kind of capabilities we
wanted to expose weren't going in quite
the direction we initially thought
i i i don't think it was accidental
that's why i mean what we imagined look
what we imagined was people who want to
do like
um
simple data taking would do it on their
phones
and it didn't help that
on android phones for example there were
many devices that were accessible on ios
phones they were not at that time
you know we had in mind but then
obviously the take a photograph on your
phone and upload it that's a thing
but
measure the barometric pressure or
something on your phone and
automatically feed it into something
automatically feed it into a form
automatically feed it into an api has
not become such a thing
um
oh one more thing the the drawing tools
that you know when you have graphics and
you you do
are those available in any way
programmatically
yes there's a function called canvas
that does that
yeah
and it's it's going to grow a bit in the
in the next release
and that's all
that's
okay how but
can that bind to a dynamic
no
should it
or maybe with another name so it's it's
documented
to
uh either
uh
well i mean it it has a documented
output form all right so those are right
so that just right the moment he started
editing it right it split from the the
original input cell and became its own
input cell
even evaluated
why doesn't that work
but why shouldn't that work
why should it work
because it's an obvious thing to do
graphics of graphics
doesn't work
yes it does
graphics of graphics will work doesn't
it no
how could i have not done that in all
these millions of years
i mean most of you like that
yeah it works
like graph works if you can you have it
as a graphics primitive like if you have
other graphics uh with that graphic no
you could have to put it in an insight i
mean if you unformat the cell there's
only one graphics box there yeah it it
it works because of
evaluation
not because of typesetting
okay but i mean graph does this and this
is something you should expect
that you can say graphics of graphics
just like you can say graph of graph
i think graphics
right the canvas is into graphics it's a
canvas right and you can't do graphics
of graph to i don't think
i think you can use show to convert uh
let's see a graph into a graphics
yeah i just tried it doesn't work
probably should but i think if you do
show if you do show of percent percent
then
it'll uh
okay i think that's a bug i think it
should work
is that a graphics now
orange border
yeah
this should work graphics of that thing
should work
and graphics of graphics should work and
graphics of canvas should work and so on
there's no reason to not have graphics
of the image
why not i think that does work now
charlie can you comment on that
certainly if i do image of this what
happens if i do image of graph graphics
of x plus y
no probably not
graphics of graphics 3d
yes that should that's worked for years
yeah that worked fine oh no the image of
graphics works but graphics
graphics of image doesn't work image of
graphics works
okay the main issue is graphics image of
many other things doesn't work
well
because we have rasterized for that okay
the issue with graphics of image is it
doesn't know where to put it
so we either make the decision
among many other things right
right yeah i mean the whole okay let's
take this raster and and convert it into
a bunch of factor directives no no no
we're not we're not going to do that no
that's going to be a raster yeah it's
just going to be rastus oh i see
it's just purely a question of whether
it has a coordinate system or not well
you may not realize this but graphics of
graphics 3d does quote quote work but it
doesn't return to graphics it returns a
graphics 3d
really
uh
yep i just tried it
yeah i mean you know in in the post
script days yes i i remember what we
used to do in the postscript days but
the you know in a post-postscript world
uh
that would have required uh
a kind of
you know uh
sort of a renderer
um
yes i understand to to make
to vector make a two-dimensional vector
thing out of that right we are
profoundly running out of time i think
that we need a discussion about things
like graphics of graphics graphics of
image and so on and we need separately
probably a custom meeting to talk about
the future of client value-like things
make sense of basically how to return
values that the main issue is this
you've got a thing
it has a user interface
how do you return a value from it
because there's one form of interaction
which is using the user interface
and there's another channel so to speak
which is actually returning programmatic
values and we've handled that nicely for
the things which are dynamic controls
where
you know we're bringing up the user
interface and it is continually and
dynamically
sending
the values into the actual back end so
to speak
but we don't have yeah and and we have
uh there's another analog which is maybe
purer than some of the others that have
been raised which is
uh system dialog input versus file
center
yes um
system dialog input returns this result
files
sorry file name center uh uh
settings
yeah
right but i think we need a more
standardized way of making that
dichotomy and a couple of others
so
that's the thing for another time i
think that should have its own custom
meeting
what is this about
oh this is
i it's it's fine i mean
we'll get to this it's just not
identifies us with ies oh i see sorry i
i wasn't aware that there was uh you
know officials
um
the
uh you know sometimes we should make a
glossary of some of these names like
road down to five because i mean it's
been with us for 30 years now it's not
going away and it's a useful
concept
i don't know what else you would call it
it might have some name in in um
uh
i can't even imagine what field would
have been given it a name
mathematical logic wouldn't have done so
can you explain what it is for the
uninitiated
oh rodentifies just means does the
function uh
burrow down inside the expression
mean it's like listable but for things
other than list
yes
it's is it a burrowing function
but it was slightly more uh whimsically
named
okay we should wrap up here
um
thanks everyone
and uh
okay
thanks